Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Colors for another episode of Colors clinic live, and we have a very special guest
just a wonderful colleague who I see eye to eye on. In so many ways, she actually interviewed me on her
podcast a couple of years ago. I hate to say, well, finally, but we are finally getting her out to
repay that favor. It's Dr. V. Dr. V is a Canadian breast cancer survivor. You,
I'm sure all our patients have heard about her as we have heavily promoted the podcast that I was
on on hers. And she is the author of Heal Breast Cancer Naturally, which is a number one Amazon
bestseller in 10 categories in five different countries. Huge book. We recommend it to all our
breast cancer patients, and even just regular other people with other cancers because it's just so
beneficial. She's the founder of breast cancer conqueror. That's what most people know her for.
And the seven essentials system that she developed. She's co-founder of my breast friend. So that
is another trademark issue that she has. Her signature process has empowered thousands, literally
thousands and thousands of women over 56 countries around the world to help them make the best
choices with cancer. So Dr. V, welcome. Appreciate you. Just appreciate you so, so, so much.
Thank you for having me and sharing my message of hope, your community. It's always encouraging to
speak to doctors who have ventured into the realm of helping people naturally and becoming more public.
I speak to colleagues that think I'm crazy for doing podcasts like this and writing books and
having a website with lots of information that we give away on because it sets us up as a target.
And maybe it does. But I believe like you do that God has us on a mission and we're here for
greater purposes than self preservation. So why don't you kind of give us your story and what brought
you down this pathway to get people understanding some foundational truth about Dr. V.
So I'm a car practice by profession and I was 1983. I was in practice for three years. So just a
little fledgling. And my father was diagnosed with pancreatic cancer. And you know, how it goes with
traditional medicine. I gave him no hope six weeks to live and he bought it to the day and he died a
horrible death and six weeks later. But throughout that whole period, you know, I knew the body's
ability to heal. And I knew given the right resources that potentially the body could heal. Now,
of course, this was advanced. So maybe it would not have made a difference. But I think it would have
made a difference in the quality of his life. And so I, you know, started researching 1983,
no internet back then. So I went to the library called some cancer clinics which were
tuned far between back then. And I realized, you know, there were things that could be done for
people with cancer. So I started applying these principles in my practice and one thing led to
another. I mean, I was seeing people from literally different countries and, you know, just a lot of
people come all over the place because the results were getting. And, you know, fast forward about,
you know, 10, 11 years later, I'm in the shower. I'm getting ready to get ready for work. And I feel
this lump in my breast. And right away, I knew, you know, was that innate gut feeling. I knew it wasn't
just a typical benign cyst. And so that started my journey with breast cancer. And, you know, I really
was shocked because I was, you know, Dr. B, the wellness warrior, you know, helping all these people
get well. And yet, here I was facing this, you know, breast cancer in my, in my breast. So I went
back to the drawing board and I said, okay, you know, I know what, you know, what cancer is and what
cancer is not. And I had to ask myself, what did I do that allowed the cancer to develop and show up in
my body? And so that's when I, you know, started looking at different options and how I would really
improve my immune system, improve my health, and we can do things to weaken the cancer. And so from
2004 to 2006, that's what I did. I really worked heavily, did a lot of research. And, you know,
there were times that I was frustrated and confused just like any other woman would be, right, with
breast cancer. There were some fears sometimes in the back of my mind, but I just kept pushing forward.
And then I felt like I had this download about the 70 essentials because I was jumping all over
the place. I didn't feel like I had a structured process. So that's when I created the 70 essentials,
you know, a step-by-step guide that if you follow, you never have to fear cancer or any disease again.
And so that first journey was, was very successful. It was quite simple. Didn't take too long.
It only took a couple of years. But then fast-forward 2015. And by then, you know, I'd sold my practice.
I was now known as the breast cancer conqueror, helping women from all over the world. Again,
you know, wellness warrior, working from son up to son down. And I did not manage my health very well.
And it caught up with me. And I, I felt another lump, you know, same place, same area. And I, you know,
I knew that there was something going on in my body. I mean, it was tired. I was stressed. I was in
sleeping well. My hormones were off. I ended up finding out I had cavitations or infections in my mouth.
And then I created the perfect storm for cancer to show up again. So this time, you know,
there was a lot more available to me as far as research. And we had learned so much from 2006 to
2015, nine years in the cancer world, you know, a lot more information. And so I, you know, started
did all kinds of testing. I did high dose vitamin C, all different kinds of supplements, nutrients.
And it took me three years. But since 2018, I've been happier and healthier than I've ever been.
Well, that's a huge praise god right there. I do want to ask you about your seven essentials. But
before that, there was something that you said that parked by ear a little bit. When you first
were diagnosed with cancer your first time, you asked yourself the question, I don't know if I can
raise it exactly the way you said it. But what did I do that may have led to this diagnosis?
Is there, do you see a big difference between a person being diagnosed with cancer and
not taking responsibility for it? Maybe just saying, why did I get this instead of asking the
honest question, why did I get this? What did I do that participated in this?
Is there a difference between being a victim and being taken responsibility for it?
Totally, totally. You know, there's the patients or clients that say, oh, why me for me?
And there's the patients that say, okay, this is showing up in my life for a reason. So what,
how did I live my life that allowed this cancer to show up and why is it showing up? So they
they approach it with curiosity and they approach it with a sense of responsibility which
is a totally different attitude about your healing and of course as you've seen, I'm sure
the victim versus the the victor, there's a huge difference in the outcome as far as their
mortality is concerned. Yeah, I had a patient ask me just yesterday, she said,
could you explain to me when you say in a, I think I must have said in a video that you have to
get to the point to be thankful for, thank God for your cancer. I don't understand that because she
thinks, you know, she said cancer is an evil thing and it's like, well, yeah, it is, but there's
still things that you can shape your life and can change you and God can use this to his glory
if you allow that no matter bad things happen all the time and it's how we look at them and how
we say, okay, how can can God be glorified in this as a as a as a Christian and it's just a different
way of looking at it that I think is healthier and you're not taking that victim mentality.
Yes, so we teach our clients to always ask the question, what is the gift?
Yeah, it's not just getting rid of the lump or the bump but it's about the transformation
that you're going to go through if you choose to to come out on the other side, a happier and healthier
person. Yeah, now let's jump into these seven essentials. These that you had downloaded to you that
that are so important and I just I just love them. If you want to walk us through that, that would
be great. Okay, then feel free to jump in or project anytime. So, essential number one is let food
be your medicine and I think nutrition is definitely at the front of everybody's mind. There's so
much information now about eating well and organic and now we know about food and how it affects
our genes. So, there's so many amazing things that can happen when we choose the right foods and
there's no one that size fits all when it comes to diet. It really depends on your genetics, on your
the health of your gut. There's just so many factors. So, people ask me what's the perfect way to eat?
Well, generally speaking as a big overview, I would say 80% raw, make sure it's organic, lots of
grains, lots of veggies. If you choose to eat protein, make sure that it's clean, hormone free,
antibiotic free, all of that, nuts and seeds. Just make sure that you're getting a lot of
trace minerals in your food as well. Yeah, we we talk, we test with kinesiology, we test for
cause on patients and it's just how it's changed over the last 20 years with patients. The most
common cause in our testing for cancer is pesticides, herbicides, chemicals from our food sources
and it's even in people that say, well, I've been eating organic for 10 years. It's there's so much
cross contamination. We are just being poisoned. At least here in America, we are, I don't know how
bad it is and cared it, but it's just awful. Yeah, it is and that brings us right into essential
number two, you know, the toxicity reduce your toxic exposure. We can't live in a bubble, but there's
things that you can do to actively reduce that exposure. So, you know, we mentioned, you know, organic as
much as you can. Look at what you have in your home, you know, there's hundreds of chemicals that will
promote breast cancer. If you're not careful with the cleaners and the sprays and the artificial
candles and all of those things, look at what you're putting on your skin because again, all these
chemicals, so many of them are what we call zenoestrogens or chemical estrogens that will mimic and
stimulate estrogen in the body. So just, you know, start with one thing at a time, you know, get rid of
the shaving cream for your legs and just use plain soap, use clean toothpaste, use clean cosmetics,
clean things to, you know, clean your home and that makes a huge dent in that toxicity level.
And then take active steps to detox your body on a regular basis. So we're, you know, we're
strong advocates of coffee enemas, you know, colonic irrigation, liver cleanses, parasite cleanses,
sauna sweating, make sure that you sweat, lymphatic drainage, lymphatic massage, all of that is
so important to get those toxins out of your body. Yeah, that's great. That's so essential,
so that no matter how well you do, I mean, and like you said, just start making some wise decisions.
You have to buy products anyhow, just make some bitter, better choices. So,
And it's so easy now compared to what 20 years ago, yeah, I said to make my stuff back then and now
it's just go to the local grocery store and you have it. Right, that's right. Okay, point number three,
number three is to balance your energy. So where one billion physical matter, right, the rest is
all energy. So how do we keep that energy balanced? Chiropractic care is going to keep your nerve system
balanced, acute puncture, exercise, you have to move your body, proper sleep. If we don't get
restorative sleep, then you're turning on cancer promoting genes, you're not detoxifying properly,
you're weakening your immune system. And then the biggest thing for me with number three is hormones,
you know, traditional medicine has really vilified women's hormones and made them afraid that if
they have an estrogen positive cancer, oh no, we have to shut down your hormones. But, you know,
our hormones don't cause cancer. We look at every 20 year old on the planet who's raging hormones,
you know, they're fine, they're healthy. And we need our hormones for brain health and gut health and
brain heart health and bone health, all those things. And if we shut down those hormones with toxic
drugs, and it opens up the way to create, you know, more cancers and more disease in the body. So
I always teach our women, first of all, find out what your hormone levels are through saliva testing.
Find out if you have a problem with methylation or metabolism of your hormones, because if you do,
and you're not breaking down your hormones properly, then there's a possibility that those excess
of estrogens could trigger cancer. And, you know, test, test to see, you know, where you are as far
as that methylation, and reduce your toxic exposure to things that stimulate estrogen, like the
chemicals you put on your skin and the sunscreens and the phthalates and the plastics, even metals,
even the metals in your mouth, which we'll talk about. Those are known as zeno-metallogens,
or, you know, the estrogen, we stimulate estrogen production when you're exposed to them.
Yeah, that's where you get into the pesticides that are herbicides, again, or even
if there's zero estrogen-like and horrible for horrible and positive breast cancers.
Yeah, that is a challenge. Because women, that's the biggest question that we get with breast
cancer patients, women that are pushed so hard by the medical profession to do the medical
aromatase inhibitors that will just literally shut down all their hormones, and everybody hates it.
You know, they all hate what it makes them feel like. It's just chemically just puts them into a chemical
slurry of dysregulation of all hormone functions. It's just horrible.
No, then they can, you know, if they have, if they're afraid of that whole estrogen story,
then do things that can help support balancing those estrogens, you know, like flax or fermented soy or
dim and calcium deglucarate, you know, all these things that could really help manage those hormone
levels in your body properly. Right. I always tell them there's ways to help pull out those
quote unquote bad estrogens without eliminating all your estrogen or progesterone that is so essential
for everything else. You talked about, well, we're really going to do it in point number four, so I'll
let you jump into that. Okay, number four is to heal the emotional wounds, and we kind of alluded to
that at the beginning of the podcast, you know, victim victor, but you know, really understanding what's
going on in your heart and your soul is so important when it comes to healing. It means, you know,
learning to love yourself, to really create healthy relationships, create healthy boundaries,
nurture that little girl inside of you, you know, make sure that she feels safe and to forgive
yourself, forgive others, let go of things in the past, and to really dive into that emotional aspect
of your life, because let's face it, even if we had the best childhood, you know, there's still
different aspects of our life where there was teenager, young adult, you know, we had challenges in
our life, and if we just stuff them and suppress them, then that energy, that emotional energy is still
lingering because that memory is stored up in our cells, and Candace Perk, you know, she was way ahead
of her time in the 80s, she wrote the book, molecules of emotions, and you know, she said, you know, mine
becomes body, because every thought you think creates those proteins that talks to every single
cell in your body. Dr. Joe D'Spenza, you are the placebo, you know, your mind has such a powerful
message to yourselves, good or bad, whatever you choose, so really, you know, looking at the power
of the mind, the power of your belief, because I'm sure you've seen this, you know, patients who
vacillate and say, well, I think I can heal, I'm not sure, and I hope this works versus this is going
to work, and I'm going to heal, and I'm going to be happy and healthy at the end of this journey,
makes a huge difference in their response. Sure, absolutely.
Yeah, that is maybe one of the key things, right? That maybe that's one of the more difficult things
to go through, you know, you can make the physical changes of what I'm going to get rid of all toxic
substances in my house, toxic shampoo and such, but what do you have to deal with some inner
wolves? Do you have, you know, that's a little bit harder, so that's one that everybody wants to skip,
you know, if I were to start over, I think I'd put that one at number one, because I, you know,
I've seen women who traveled the world, then everything spent hundreds of thousands of dollars on
their treatments, but they never addressed, you know, what was between here and here, they just,
they didn't make it. Yeah, we see that time, but I get to the more difficult cases of the ones
that have just an anxiety that is just relentless. Yeah, yeah. All right, number five, this is the one
that you really kind of learned this on your second to journey, right? Yes, yes, I did. I had done some work
before or on removing the metals in my mouth, but number five, to embrace biological dentistry,
it means to really take a look at chemically what's going on in your mouth and then energetically.
So if we start with chemically, you know, if we look at metal fillings, we know those are
50% mercury, and that's one of the most toxic elements on the planet, and it's going to cause all kinds
of neurodegenerative issues and suppress your immune system. It's also a metallo estrogen,
right? Stimulates estrogen. So we want to make sure that we remove those metals from our mouth
properly by using, you know, biological dentists that are certified in the smart technique where
they're certified by, you know, there's different biological organizations, but make sure they're
certified. And then there's the root canals, right? Root canals are basically dead tooth. It's a
dead appendix or a dead gallbladder. It's the same thing. Full of, you know, anaerobic bacteria, no
matter how aceptic you try to make it, and that can drip toxins into your body. But recently,
though interesting talking about root canals, I discovered something called regenerative endodonics,
where they are actually removing, they take that root canal, and they remove the binders and
everything that they have in there that are toxic, flush it out with frequencies and sound, make it
aceptic, and then they put in a bio ceramic material that is non-toxic. And it fills all the little
crevices and it works really well. I had a client who went to LA to have that done. It was amazing.
When she pulled out that thing from the old root canal, it was all black and full of mold and
bacteria. It's pretty fascinating. So that's something to do. Yeah, it was for me. It was for me
regenerative orthodontics. Then the endodonics. The next thing is looking at your mouth energetically. So
your teeth are connected to your organs through the acupuncture meridian system. And if there's a
hunk of metal or if there's a root canal, that can really affect that meridian. And there are
specific meridians in the top and the bottom on the teeth that are connected to the breast meridians.
And we see the connection all the time. Cavitation is another thing. A cavitation is an infection in
the bone. After you've had a tooth pulled, if it wasn't cleaned out properly, it'll create an
infection literally eat away at the bone. Cavitation means hole in the bone. And that can cause
some issues. And I found out, in my case, so I had cavitation up here, number 14, which is left
breast meridian. One down here, I forget the number down there, 20 something left breast meridian.
So there's always that connection. And we can see that on thermography too. They have red spots
or their mouth is all red. We know definitely you need to clean out that mouth.
We see we do thermography. We see that all the time. But in fact, you can actually just see a
tooth that is just right down to that breast. It's just like a boy.
Another thing to do to help get better, right?
That's fine. Okay, number six.
Yeah, so this is all the therapeutic plants and herbs that people want to know about. What do I take
to build my immune system up to kill the cancer cells? And there's a whole plethora. I mean, if you
get the book, you'll see there's like over 700 references to all the different studies that show
which products work and why. So basic things like vitamin D, just keep your vitamin D levels optimal
between 80 and 100. That in itself will help you to prevent breast cancer and it'll really ensure
that you can heal properly. Make sure you have all your trace minerals like zinc, selenium,
magnesium. Your vitamin A is also very important. And then look at therapeutic plants like
curcumin and wormwood and there's different formulations like polyMBA and
porous cell, which are basically different things that are designed to kill cancer cells.
Even concentrations of blueberries can really help to turn off those cancer-promoting genes.
Broccoli sprouts are very important, self-warfing, turns on over too many genes. So there's a whole
system that we use to help support nutritionally and then to really target those cancer cells.
Yeah. How important is that? And we get to argue with sometimes when we have a phone consult
with a spouse that will say, well, if there's studies on this, why are the regular doctors used?
You know, it takes you literally 30 seconds to do a Google scholar search on the curcumin or vitamin
deal. You'll see 600 pages of studies. And yet, they're never read.
It's never acknowledged. It's kind of sad actually. And you can't patent these things, right?
Oh, so there's no money in it, right? There's no money to be made. Yeah.
Okay. Number seven. Number seven. The last one, it's all about keeping a pulse on your health
and really embracing early detection. And so we recommend a lot of tests outside of conventional
medicine. When we think of early detection, what do we think of, you know, mammograms? I mean,
the pink month is coming up, right? And so we teach women, you have a lot of other choices.
You know, if you choose to do a mammogram, know the consequences, you know, the radiation,
the compression, the problems, it could cause. And then back it up with something else,
like an ultrasound. If you do hemography, if hemography is a great tool, you know, it does not
give off radiation. It looks at the physiological changes and the tissue of the breast.
Back that up with an ultrasound as well, you know, because that's going to give you a different window
to look at. And then there's, you know, breast self-exam, so we talked about, you know, you mentioned,
you know, my breast friend. So my breast friend was created originally through the mammic care
foundation. And maybe you learned on a model similar to this on how to do a proper breast exam.
So the mammic care foundation has taught thousands of doctors around the world for the last 30 years.
And this is the model that they used. So they asked me to take this model to the general public. So women
would now have access to this model. So we made it look pretty, put it in the pretty box,
comes with an instructional video, a little booklet, but it teaches you what to look for and what to
feel. So you see these lumps here. And then how to feel and where to feel. So it's a whole system
that really teaches women, you know, the proper way of doing a breast exam. Because if you can find
something, well, let me show you this picture here, the average size lump that a woman finds when
she's not trained, properly trained as the size of a ping pong ball, when she's properly trained, she
can find something the size of a P. So a huge difference. Big difference there. Yeah.
That small and it hasn't spread. Your survival rate is 15 years over 88%. So, you know, it's a big game
change or if you can find it small. And then there's, you know, all the blood tests that we recommend.
Of course, you know, your vitamin D levels, vitamin A magnesium. Look at your inflammatory markers
because if there's lots of inflammation in the body, then chances are you're, you know, producing
cancer cells. And we use, you know, different tests. I don't know, I'm sure you're familiar with RGCC.
I'm not sure if you use it or not, but RGCC and there's other companies now that filter the blood
and look at circulating tumor cells because if they cut out the tumor, that's great, but there's
still cancer floating around in your body, right? And you have to address that root cause. So,
it gives us these tools to be able to manage things more effectively. Yeah, that's great.
Well, we just appreciate all your work that you're doing. Anything
crit in your life? That is that you're promoting? Well, we always have, well, we used to have
live retreats, but now we have virtual retreats. We just finished one of those. And actually in
a couple of weeks, we're doing a small live retreat in Sarasota where we rent a house on the beach and
we bring women together, hang out for four days or so. We get bring in IVs, different practitioners who
do biometric testing. We do meditation. We just eat well and just hang out and share our
journey. So, we're doing one in a couple of weeks and we'll do one again in the spring. That's
fantastic. Yeah. Well, you are a ginormous encouragement to a lot of people, even those with our press
cancer. So, I just wanted to acknowledge you. We're going to have information about your website. So,
patients and listeners can get to that. See the tools that you have available. Utilize your service.
I just want to thank you. Appreciate you. Thank you. Yeah. Thank you for all that you do, but as well,
Dr. Connors. Again, thank you very much. Appreciate all our listeners. This episode of Connors,
clinic live, Dr. B. Thank you again.